you guys
have obviously you know done something
special with generation now i feel like
um
you know dram like you being who you are
and being a dj and and
like successfully and we're not just
talking about successfully doing the
label [ __ ]
like we're talking about like uzi's one
of the biggest
[ __ ] artists of the last decade jack
harlow's
superstar right now so like not only are
you like doing your thing because
you know with your connections you could
do your thing with whoever is on your
roster but to like
really really um
be like a prominent source of new talent
in
the music industry um it's just
impressive man like
you guys have built something really
special no i appreciate that um it's
it's very rewarding like
you know like just to think about
my career and the successes i've had as
a dj and
you know we've had as a um coming up as
the affiliates and
and you know putting things together and
projects and and doing it and just
really elevating and
you know and in some senses it feels
like reinvention
you know and just even somebody brought
it up today like you know like
or i put a tweet up that i just found on
on twitter and this guy said um he said
um dj drama really went from ti to gz to
uzi to jack harlow that's crazy
you know and i was like you know it was
it was that was like the highest praise
for me how i felt you know
i mean [ __ ] dude i tweeted uh earlier or
later last year
you're the greatest of all time yeah i i
appreciate that i forgot about that you
did that was
that was an interesting combo yeah i was
watching that um
that that versus and i was like yo like
drama's got his hands all over this
entire like
like atlanta is arguably the most
important city
in like it's new york obviously for sure
but at like
atlanta is where everything is the
culture starts here
and everyone else follows atlanta and
it's been like that for
15 years i'd say even maybe 20 20 maybe
20
right i feel like atlanta's had the most
dominant run
in hip-hop over and like i just don't
feel like anyone has ever
had more moments and
influence and just um have been a part
of more history than you
good-looking and by the way amazing dj
as well
i appreciate that yeah um we try to
cover all
all grounds all capacity and you know
it's just like
it really is because you know a lot of
[ __ ] like i've been doing it for so long
and
you know just just to i
i and we try not to get comfortable on
what we've accomplished already
and then you know just like being able
to
navigate and you know being a dj is like
because we we play music and we've been
able to navigate through
hip hop through a lot of times it's like
you know that keeps me
on the cusp and keeps me like really
addicted to new [ __ ] like at all times
you know i'm saying so
um so yeah i mean it's my my my dj hat
has
has been very helpful and you know the
career as an executive and
you know finding and you know helping
new talent and you know
turning into what we did and of course
you know slew of hit records
in your own right you know for sure